these deep-sea mushroom-shaped organisms
don't fit in any known subdivision of
the animal kingdom they're flat disks
and a stock with a mouth on the end and
are kind of like coral and comb jellies
but not exactly so researchers are
baffled and Airbus is patenting virtual
reality sensory isolation headgear which
aside from audio-visual components
include squirting smells up passengers
noses so you can completely forget
you're flying in an airplane Vsauce
Kevin here this is mine
Letta awed mented reality glasses make
science fiction a reality they use the
natural world as the focus of the
computer interface creating a real-time
map of your surroundings and allowing
you to interact with Holograms it's the
first machine to allow two people to
view and interact with digital
information from different perspectives
while holding eye contact so for
instance you could play Minecraft with a
friend in the same physical space the
interface is designed by the same guy
who did the Iron Man movies and they
hope to implement this in everything
from healthcare and engineering to
education and gaming jake from vsauce3
tried them on and said this said Rossum
want eSport Limousin is a sports car
that runs on salt water it has a top
speed of 217 miles per hour and uses an
electrolyte flow cell power system to
power four electric motors electrical
power for the drivetrain is created by
using salt water as an electrolyte and
the solution is held in to 200 liter
tanks allowing you to drive up to 373
miles on a single charge and they just
received approval to test it on roads in
Europe UCLA biologists successfully used
a genetic remote control to slow the
aging process by activating a gene in
the nervous system or intestines of
fruit flies they can see the aging
process slow and they hope this research
can eventually be used to delay the
onset of diseases in humans it turns out
Stonehenge is way bigger than we thought
using radar laser scanners and
magnetometers researchers uncovered 17
new chapels ritual shrines massive pits
and a 108 footlong burial mound
containing a gigantic wooden building
that they believed was used for rituals
involving dead bodies these new findings
drastically change our understanding of
Stonehenge which was reshaped for
hundreds of years beginning in 3100 BC
4mm is a jetpack forerunners developed
at Arizona State University it enhances
human speed and agility with the goal of
allowing any soldier to run a
four-minute mile
DARPA asked for assistance in developing
Augmented ability exoskeletons for
able-bodied soldiers and trials of the
jetpack have shown its ability
to make users run faster while exerting
less energy this shape-shifting
architecture concept expands and
contracts based on temperature it uses
shape memory polymer joints connected to
plywood to expand the original surface
area four times the idea is to create
architecture that isn't so rigid is more
attuned to the environment but they
admit real-world applications on a large
scale are ways off new ultralight
ceramic cubes could be used to build
lighter stronger airplanes trucks and
batteries the nano scale struts can
recover from being crushed and they're
light enough to float through the air
ceramic usually shatters when drops due
to its weight but at the nano scale the
material is recoverable from compression
and they're now working to apply this
nano structure design to lithium air
batteries finally I know uses street
lights and time lapse to create a
kaleidoscope of Tokyo
I'm gonna leave you with smart
headlights that can adapt to any
conditions at highway speeds and as
always thanks for watching